on today's edition of lunch urn Jason my
videographer is going to surprise us
with a question the social skills matter
as an entrepreneur absolutely you're in
the business of customer service in any
kind of business that you are in right
even when you're in an online business
and you do retail just online so social
skills matter not only to the frontline
customers but it's also matters for your
employees making them happy and just
everyone around you happy right I think
you have to know what you're good at and
go all in on that as an example with
Toronto dance salsa the company that
were right now right we work together at
alex has much better social skills than
I do he's a he's a talker he's the guy
who can like jagger off i'm much more
the marketing guy than the sales guy and
so I spend my time doing things that are
business building strategy building if
it relied on me making sales calls the
business would tank and so I think it's
understanding what your strengths are
and what you're really good at and what
you enjoy doing I think this is just an
element of you don't have to have really
great social skills I think you just
have to you have to care right like I
can still talk to people I don't talk to
them same way Alex would but I still
care about them right and I care about
their success and I want them to have a
good experience when they're working
with me you're working with my company
and so if you are the kind of person who
is not a Type A personality I wouldn't
freak out and think I can't be a
successful entrepreneur because I see
Donald Trump and Richard Branson all
these guys killing it right there doing
a while at what they're doing because
that's their great skill set you're
going to see Alex kicking up a ton of
noise being an antenna media you know
making tons of partnerships and striking
up and seeing relationships because
that's what it's really good i hope that
he does that right if he doesn't then
then we're screwed i can say that my
mother is my channel say what i want to
say and so there's a bunch of other
entrepreneurs you've never heard of
where if you look at you know the
richest people in the world a lot of
them are entrepreneurs and a lot of
you've never heard of because they went
in all on their strengths which aren't
being
the type-a personality so I don't think
you have to stress out too much I think
it's important that you care and that
you you know treat people well but you
don't have to be a super type-a
personality friendly over-the-top
personality to be able to be a
successful entrepreneur I think that's a
great point you don't have to be type a
or you know extroverted going out with
clients all the time and whatnot I think
the biggest thing is and this is
something you can learn is just when
you're talking to them I find the most
positive responses when sort of I light
up like when someone's talking and
they're talking to me and I'm like
really like I'm excited about listening
to it right it's something that you can
sort of fake at least at the beginning
if you're not that's not something you
know that you're used to doing but not
faking the send stuff I don't want to
listen to them I'm not gonna acknowledge
them but more of like bring that out
right I think some social skills are you
know you're born with and others you can
learn and you can pick up it's not
something where if you're not a Type A
or not that you can't have those
qualities right the whole point is to
improve yourself as just as a person
right on your path to being a great
entrepreneur so just for me in my
experience that's what I find every time
someone's talking to me I just I put
energy into the conversation and even
when I'm exhausted i force myself to do
it right when I don't want to when I'm
not in the mood I'm in a bad mood if I'm
talking to someone it's like I'm onstage
I'm in front of the camera and I'm like
hey how's it going right and that just
feeds into them and people always are
more responsive whether or not i'm on
the inside I'm not maybe feeling that
today cool so there you have it that's
our impromptu answer from the question
from jason and i'm going to give alex
and impromptu question to ask you guys
to believe in the comments below what's
the best way to change the flow of a
conversation if it's going down ok i
like it leave in the comments will join
the discussion thank you guys for
watching continue to believe and we'll
see you soon